Speaker 1: So we're going to talk today about
the outlook politically in the United States
over the next couple of election cycles, and
we're going to have two very different conversations
in this first segment.
First, I'm going to talk about what I believe
is an overtly black and white approach to
figuring out what the general strategy of
the left should be over the next couple of
election cycles based on what happened Tuesday.
The second piece of it is going to be very
tactical, actually, it's going to be very
much about talking points and how to fight
on very specific issues, the messaging of
the right.
Both of these are important, but let's start
with the bigger picture first.
There are two conflicting interpretations
that are being repeated uncritically in a
sense about what happened on Tuesday.
Now, what happened on Tuesday was very bad
for Democrats, and it bodes very poorly.
It does not signal that 2022 is going to be
great for Democrats and maybe even 2024, and
we'll talk about that a little bit later.
But one reaction to what happened Tuesday
is Whoa.
Democrats went too far left India Walton Socialist
and Buffalo New York got got defeated easily
by a write in candidate.
Democrats need to come back to the middle.
The reaction by many to what happened in Virginia.
Terry McAuliffe losing there to Glenn Youngkin
after Ralph Northam won by nine in 2017, Democrat
won by nine now Republican, ended up winning
by a couple of points.
The reaction there has been Democrats need
to go further to the left, this centrist establishment
milquetoast Terry McAuliffe.
That's not what is going to lead Democrats
to victory in the future.
And the truth is the world is just more complicated
than that, and unfortunately, partially because
of the way corporate media is structured and
functions, and partially because we have a
tendency to want simple one factor explanations
for things.
A lot of these false Black-White dichotomies
are not going to lead to any success for the
left, which ultimately is what I care about.
So let's look at a couple of examples.
Here's one headline from Common Dreams, which
says progressives on the Virginia loss corporate
Democrats have only themselves to blame.
It's conservative Dems who've ensured that
every day for the last several months, the
headlines are about how we aren't delivering
paid leave, prescription drug reform, eldercare
or voting rights, and that the problem is
that if the Democratic candidate had been
much more to the left in Virginia, Virginia
would have been held by Democrats.
And we're going to link to this article and
you can analyze it and think about it.
Contrasting narrative is about socialist India.
Walton in Buffalo was a bad idea, incumbent
Brown declares Buffalo mayor write in win
over Socialist India Walton This a New York
Post article.
New York Post is sort of like Fox News owned
by News Corp.
The incumbent Democratic mayor of Buffalo,
running as a write in candidate, declared
victory Tuesday night as he held a nearly
20 point lead over his Democratic Party opponent.
India Walton, a socialist backed by many high
profile progressives, refused to concede to
Mayor Brown in the highly publicized contest
until her campaign sees all the votes.
And this has led to a number of arguments
that the problem is that that's too far left.
Now here's the reality both are true.
Both are true.
How can both be true?
Well, it is true that socialism isn't very
popular in the United States.
And right now, there aren't many socialists,
and that could be a factor in Buffalo.
It's it's plausible that in Buffalo, one of
the reasons that India Walton didn't win and
lost to a write in candidate is that there's
not that many socialists in Buffalo, and we
learned from the 2020 Democratic Party that
ideas Democratic primary rather, ideas that
seem popular on Twitter and Reddit are not
actually as popular among the average Democratic
voter.
That is true in a sense, and India Walton
being a socialist could be a factor.
Now some are saying race is a factor, although
the incumbent is black and there's all sorts
of different arguments being made.
But at least when it comes to the Buffalo
mayoral race, it doesn't seem that being a
socialist helped India Walton, so that's a
consideration.
At the same time, Terry McAuliffe was a milquetoast,
uninspiring centrist Democrat in Virginia,
and that was a factor there.
There were also other factors in Virginia
the fact that the election for a long period
of time was run as a sort of referendum on
Trump when Trump wasn't even running.
And Youngkin was sort of careful not to denounce
nor embrace Donald Trump.
So that was a factor.
There were a lot of different factors the
fact that the right very successfully played
on fear and anger over critical race theory,
which isn't even being taught to kids in Virginia,
OK?
But the common thread in both elections is
that voters were motivated by fear and anger
to vote for someone other than Terry McAuliffe
in Virginia and India, Walton in Buffalo,
New York.
Fear and anger motivate people more effectively
than, Hey, we're going to do green energy
or we're going to replace some police with
social workers or whatever the case may be
in Buffalo.
It was sort of traditional Democrat Byron
Brown who did it and said, You don't want
that.
You don't want that.
This is safer.
That's dangerous.
You should be afraid of that.
In Virginia, it was radical Republican Glenn
Young and different populations.
Virginia is more of a 50-50 state overall.
Buffalo is a I believe Joe Biden got like
seventy seven percent of the vote or no, but
maybe it was sixty seven.
Joe Biden won Buffalo easily in 2020, but
its more Democratic establishment, rather
than like progressive socialist Democrats.
So yes, Democrats ran a terrible campaign
in Virginia focused on Trump, who wasn't really
involved.
McAuliffe could have won if the climate were
actually, we are running against Trump the
way Biden did.
That's totally plausible.
Would we be having a different conversation
right now?
But the takeaway here is the Democratic Party
electorate is more centrist than it seems
on Twitter and Reddit.
We learned that in the 2020 primary, but at
the same time, there is no one explanation
as to what Democrats need to do and the first
mistake.
If we even want to have this conversation
is we can't restrict ourselves to an analysis
analysis that is to win.
Democrats need to move to the middle or to
win.
Democrats need to move to the left.
There is not one thing Democrats need to do.
And in mayoral elections vs. state Senate
and Rep vs. Senate and House of Representatives
governor and president, there is not one answer.
And unless we can first agree, there is not
one answer, we're probably not going to get
more productive conversations, unfortunately.